last week conservative commentator Matt
Walsh posted a video addressed to Dylan
Mulvaney a trans influencer in which he
spoke a number of truths truths like
this
Dylan
if that is the most attractive you will
ever look then I don't even want to
imagine what you'll look like when
you're at your ugliest
you do not pass as a as an attractive
woman or as a woman at all uh even with
50 pounds of makeup and plastic surgery
and clever lighting tricks even then you
still cannot Escape what you really are
and what you will always be you have
successfully shed whatever parts of you
were masculine perhaps at least on the
surface nobody would ever describe you
as masculine or manly so you've got that
going but your femininity quotient has
not increased at a rate commensurate
with the loss of your masculinity
um you may not be masculine but you also
aren't feminine instead you are you are
weird and artificial you are
manufactured and lifeless you are
unearthly and Eerie you are like some
kind of human deep fake that's what you
are and on our raw stream which is a
satirical comedy show where we jokingly
discuss the issues of the day we
suggested that Matt had gone too far and
tease them gently about what he said he
responded on Twitter to defend his right
to State the truth and criticize people
he disagrees with now we believe in
Matt's right to criticize people he
disagrees with without fear of being
canceled or attacked and among the many
reasons we will gladly defend Matt's
right to criticize others without being
canceled or attack is that we also want
the right to criticize people we
disagree with people like Matt which is
why we were surprised to find out we're
now canceled for disagreeing with him
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
okay so it's been uh a week since my
brief but now Infamous segment on this
show about trans activist Dylan Mulvaney
that as you know all I did in the
segment was speak honestly to Dylan and
about Dylan a man who degrades and
appropriates Womanhood while Shilling
for child mutilation and sterilization
it does all of it
[Music]
in order to frame those points I'm going
to play a quick Montage of some
right-of-center media figures and
podcasters sharing their criticisms of
my Mulvaney comments and what you'll
hear in these clips doesn't come close
to representing the harshest rebukes
that have been directed at me but they
do capture the basic point that all my
critics have been trying to make in one
form or another with varying levels of
outrage listen here's my take on it is
uh
and I you know obviously I'm much softer
generally but like there's nothing he
said that isn't true but it accomplishes
nothing and I will absolutely say yeah
it's mean
yeah Matt Walsh is being mean I mean
come on Matt Walsh insults Dylan
Mulvaney as Eerie weird and bizarre you
can get the point across without saying
that the major divide on this video is
whether or not the language was a little
too harsh towards Dylan I mean
do you reckon he's into her
it sort of does look like the sort of
thing somebody would say that when
they're slightly obsessed with somebody
yeah exactly look factually he's not
wrong yeah is he
no
factually yeah
I I don't look if your job is to win
hearts and Minds
I don't think this is the best way of
doing it what if it's your job to get
clicks online again but do clicks lead
to changing of opinion no I I don't
think he's trying to change anyone's
opinion what do you think he's trying to
do then
uh
he's trying to make people on his side
feel like he's done something cool and
said something that they think I think
do you think that yeah yeah well you're
trying to change Dylan
yeah I completely agree I completely
agree I just I just look at that and
just go
even people on his own side were like
hold on a bit mate there are no hard
feelings we can disagree and all that
it's fine
I could have done without the snagness
and the lame cheap shot from the
trigonometry guys at the end especially
in a video where they're supposed to be
lecturing me about the value of taking
the high road okay when you're going to
do that you can't start the video by
insulting me but we'll leave that uh to
the side for now you'll notice the
connecting thread okay they all agree
that I'm right that what I said is
factually correct but I think that it
goes too far by saying it out loud
Mulvaney's the one running around like
some cartoon of a woman passing out camp
in the full segment which we encourage
you to watch Matt says we are canceled
along with fellow YouTubers Tim Paul the
quartering Sydney Watson and Amala
ekpenobi a weird mix of attractive
right-wing women and men like us who've
seen better days it's all a bit
frustrating as this is our third
cancellation this week and the admin
alone has been horrendous now to be
clear Matt we have no personal animosity
towards you and as you say in your
segment you have none towards us
Constantin wrote a very positive review
of your movie and we then interviewed
you about it to help promote the film we
were not aware you were experiencing a
pylon and it was not Our intention to
join in it we were just reacting to your
video live on air without any context
I'll also hold my hands up and say I got
into a Twitter spat with you that I
regret I deleted a tweet that crossed
the line and apologized these
conversations should have happened in
private or at least somewhere where no
one would have seen them maybe next time
Matt we have a row we can do it on
clubhouse I forgot my Clubhouse anyway
you're probably unfamiliar with the
comedic nature of our raw shows where we
spend 90 of the time doing ridiculous
accents and making stupid jokes
hello I'm from Trinidad
Trinidad in Tobago
my comment about you being into Dylan
Mulvaney was just a throwaway line it
was not meant as a cheap show so let's
get into the actual substance of our
disagreement while neither of us is
conservative and we have very different
views to you on many issues this is
actually a subject where we are on the
same side just in case you're not aware
of our work here's a quick recap in 2019
when the mutilation of children you
mentioned was being ignored by most of
the mainstream and ALT media here in
Britain we two comedians working in an
awoke industry interviewed posie Parker
a controversial gender critical activist
on our YouTube channel we knew we were
risking having our Channel deleted
demonetized or getting a strike
when we released it YouTube surprise
surprise deleted it for hate speech and
gave us a warning basically the first
step to having your channel deleted we
organized a media fight back and it was
eventually reinstated reaching millions
of people even now four years later we
still get regular emails from people who
say that video saved them from
transitioning taking puberty blockers
and so on since that time we've hosted
dozens of people on this subject
including a mother who transitioned her
children and regretted it a
whistleblower from the Tavistock gender
Clinic the clinic was shut down
following an investigation not saying
our interview caused it but it was part
of the coverage that did we've
interviewed authors and academics who
studied this issue and raised the alarm
like this
and this
we've also interviewed trans people who
are critical of the extremes of gender
ideology like this
and this
we've also highlighted the cancel
culture that punishes people who speak
out against it like this
and this
and this you can count on the fingers of
one hand the number of British comics
and satirists who are willing to mock
this crazy ideology we are two of them
we don't bring this up to suggest that
we've done more than you or anyone else
on this issue we don't talk publicly
about the threats of violence we receive
for talking about this issue because we
don't want to play the victim we're just
saying we're fighting the same fight the
reason we disagree with you is not that
we aren't sufficiently angry at the
brainwashing and ensuing mutilation of
children the introduction of penis
wielding creeps into women's prisons or
the invasion of women's sports by men
who've taken more steroids than the
liver King the reason we disagree with
you is precisely because we think all of
those things are awful and want to stop
them like you do we just think that
unlike much of your other work this
particular video will have alienated
more people than it brought over to our
side and trust me we both have plenty of
experience in pissing people off we made
two specific criticisms of your approach
in this particular video first we said
you were preaching to the choir instead
of attempting to win hearts and minds
and you can see this in your response
you were speaking to your audience who
are like you and like us justifiably
angry and you're vocalizing that anger
for them which makes them feel
understood it makes them feel empowered
what are they empowered to do exactly
these people already agree with you you
aren't changing their minds you're
creating more angry people in the world
who now feel that the way to deal with
the spread of gender ideology is what
calling a trans influencer ugly as
someone who looks like a cross between
Harry Potter and a lesbian I don't have
a problem with people making fun of
someone's appearance online
but I'm just not sure it achieves
anything the other criticism we made of
your approach is that we don't think
this is the way to win people over of
course No One Believes anything you say
could possibly change Dylan Mulvaney's
mind women can be stubborn like that
Matt but it's not Mulvaney's mind we
need to change and this right here is
the core of our disagreement we believe
the way to stop the proliferation of
this craziness is to convince the silent
scared ignorant and disinterested
majority that this matters and and this
is the really important bit we have to
convince them that they aren't bigots or
bad people for being concerned about
these issues let's be honest neither you
or us cares about being called names on
the internet but most people don't want
to be on the nasty side of this debate
here in Britain a small but growing
number of politicians like Rosie
Duffield who is actually on the left are
slowly starting to push back against
this ideology we need to make it easier
for politicians to talk about this issue
without immediately being lumped in with
people who are considered hateful
whether rightly or wrongly most people
who are on the fence aren't going to be
persuaded by insults and anger no matter
how righteous the anger or how accurate
the insults we have to convince them
that we are right not only factually but
also morally we have to convince them
that we are on the right side of History
and we don't believe that calling
Mulvaney ugly is the best way to do that
sorry now we know that your cancellation
of us is tongue Intrigue you aren't
trying to take down our YouTube channel
or get us banned on Twitter but the idea
that because we disagreed with your
specific approach in one specific video
we don't care enough about the issue is
just not true you care and we care so
let's keep working and carry on being
the most effective Nazi transfer bigots
we can be and if we disagree about the
best way to do that let's do what adults
do make sniping videos about each other
on YouTube
[Music]
yeah it is
there we go